we're very confident in all the vaccines
that we're
using and i think it's important for
people to
to bear in mind that all of them
we think are effective in delivering a
high degree of protection
against uh serious illness and and death
which is the
the most important thing we'll be
continuing to study the
uh the results the effectiveness of the
of the vaccine
roll out and that's going very very fast
indeed and we'll be looking at the uh
the ways in which uh the
the population is starting to to respond
to
the the vaccines as we prepare to
say what we're going to do in the week
of the
of the 22nd and what kind of road map we
want to lay out
but if it's the case that it isn't
actually stopping people capturing or
indeed
passing on the virus is this going to
mean a delay
to the relaxation of lockdown
we think that all the vaccines that
we're using both the vaccines that we're
currently using
are effective in as i say in in stopping
uh serious disease and death we also
think in particular in the case of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine that there's
uh good evidence that it is uh stopping
transmission as well i think
67 percent uh reduction in transmission
uh with the the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine so uh
they remain a massive benefit to uh
our country and uh the population as we
as we go through the
pandemic and i've no doubt that
vaccines generally are going to offer
the way out
and with every
day that goes by you can see that
medicine is
is slowly getting the upper hand over
the disease
what is the government doing to combat
the threat of new variants
for example do you need to go further on
border controls
with border controls obviously we have
amongst the toughest
border controls anywhere in the world
and you all sorts of steps that you have
to go through including
a lengthy period of quarantine if you
come back from abroad
but they are most effective
border controls when you've got the rate
of infection
down in your country and
at the moment as you know we've we've
greatly reduced the rate of infection
from
the peak where it was a few weeks ago
but it's still
extremely high and for border controls
ready to make that
that final difference so that you can
isolate new variances
as they come in you need to have
infections uh really much lower so you
can track them
as they spread don't forget uh that
we in the uk are capable of of seeing
variants arise
here uh just in the in the uk the
obvious the
the uk the kent variant arose here
but that doesn't mean that we're not
going to be relying very much on
border controls as we get the rates of
infection
down overall stopping it coming in
tracking the people
who have the new variants how concerned
are you about the south african variant
i mean obviously we are seeing
surge testing taking place
we believe that our vaccines are
effective in in combating
a serious disease and death against uh
against all
uh variants but the most important thing
is that
the vaccinologists the scientists
are getting ever faster
and more expert in coming up with the
new
uh vaccines and the variance of the
vaccines
if you like that enable us to defeat
the the virus so yes we're we're
doing everything we can to contain new
variants but
we're also increasingly confident as i
say
that science medicine is gaining the
upper hand over
coronavirus and all its variants will
school terms
on uh february 22nd or in the week of
february the 22nd we will be setting out
uh much more about what we're going to
do to to help
uh pupils catch up to help the kids
catch up for the learning that they've
lost and
as i said last week this is the single
biggest priority now
uh for the government we can do things
at great pace to try and
remedy the the gaps in provision for
health care the
the the loss of health care that people
have suffered we can speed up court
cases
but we've got to work flat out now as a
country
as a society to remedy the loss of
learning that kids have had and
so there's a big program underway as you
know already the a billion pound more
another 300 million pounds we just
announced for catch up for
for one-on-one tutorials but we will
certainly be setting out
uh gavin williamson will also be setting
out in more detail
exactly what we want to do to help kids
catch up and bounce back from this
pandemic because it's going to take
a while to do that